lahter with Crowder studios is protected
exclusively by Walther and hopper
uh durwood Crowder live descends upon
the University of Michigan October 25th
at the power center in Ann Arbor sir of
your tickets now and louder with greater
calm / - costume contest and private
Mudd Club after-party details to follow
viewer beware
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the poking holes in the
hearings from today it's because III
that's an hour and a half two hours
three I don't know how much of my life
that I won't get back so we're gonna go
through all of that here today sorry -
Paul Joseph Watson who won't be on the
show yeah sorry - Josh wolf we had a
bump because of so much to get to
everything you need to know about the
hearings we wanted to dissect it and
give you the the need to know is along
with what you'll probably be be told
from the media and after this I'm going
to grab a very large vessel of beer did
I say peer I mean I'm at raped someone
I do feel raped you're right yes you
look in the lexicon today we'll get to
that in a second questions day before
introduce everybody hear the expression
they go low we go high sometimes there's
a you've got to rise above it sometimes
you got to step on that in that's that's
biggie you know to talk yeah how do you
go high if you're being falsely accused
of rape allegedly comment to me where's
the line between us they go low I'm just
gonna stomp them long enough suck or
kick them all they go low
bruising with me of course we have
quarter black Garrett yeah and then we
have a Gerald Morgan I'm too pissed
about what else no one no wine today -
Matt don't have a beer we are I've got
to manage this orchestra pit here we
have in third chair Owen Benjamin huge
pianists calm and we have mike Ward has
been here all this week yes Mike Weir -
yeah and your podcast is two-drink
minimum Fridays on compo media to drink
minimum
whoa running a train ass non-stop rape
we're gonna go through not all the
hearings but also the fact that the left
they've become the modern religious
Puritans they'd be kind of Church
flighty now how did that happen equate
drinking with rape and fraternities with
with rape jokes with something by the
way I think we all agree everyone in
this room can we all agree okay that if
Cavanaugh raped as many people who claim
have raped him right life in prison very
very bad prison because what's it up to
now like 119
will claim the knees right them I mean
he must be the most successful serial
rapist ever and he's drank and 14 beers
of rape yes as opposed to our
quarterback who's drinking drinking
purple driver so we're gonna get into
that but of course we still have to do
our job because this is a news on
Wednesday before we get to everything
else before we get to what happened
today in the year not Wednesday before
this or a number of last minute
accusations against Brett Kavanaugh so
this comes from Mediaite
and that NBC News the latest of whom
before we get to the hearings she once
threatened to kill her ex-boyfriends
newborn yeah and there was on the single
condition that you identify the rapist
or serial flasher as the man called
Brett Kavanaugh I was raped by Brett cab
no I was raped by Brett Kavanaugh no it
was me I was raped by Brett Kavanaugh no
me I was raped by Brett Kavanaugh
no assume is gonna party someone else
now when was this
if nothing historically accurate that
was swedish chef in there the voice that
you hear of well of course not he's not
here it's not my cord injury but I
wasn't there and Brett Kavanaugh
[Laughter]
hilarious one of the Cavanaugh accusers
who came forward I wanna make sure I get
this correct it was Julie sweat Nick see
that must have been rough was that name
she made a sexual harassment complaint
against her former employer New York
Life Insurance guess who rep Gus erector
same fern run by Deborah Katz who now
represents Christine Ford oh that's
that's all too convenient so all of us
the story broke at 7 p.m. and it fell
apart before lawrence O'Donnell even at
the chance to broadcast as menstrual
cramps by 10 people go haul ass to the
same weight firm this doesn't seem to
really add up this whole thing is
completely become a sideshow and it's
obviously irritated Cavanaugh as you'll
see when we get to the clips but if he
can come out of this relatively on
supreme court justice which may explain
his recent statements
by the way that's why it still looks
like I have a little bit of mascara very
hard to wipe that off yeah people who
aren't familiar just you YouTube crash
the plane ultimate warrior promo there
you go it all makes sense
is it judge or justice what's the
official term now it's justice it's
justice
yeah he's graduated to justice cuz these
fault like these accusations either
break a man or clarify them yes didn't
go through weeks of rape allegations
would be called judge no no no it's at
this point who wants to be a judge on
the Supreme Court anymore this should be
a good gig to claim you raped like a
donkey when you were seven even you
couldn't bring your shirt those fresh
stains on your shirt or that it was from
a shirt I just got this shirt because I
wanted to lose shirt I literally just
got it finished no I only flew one shirt
I'm like I want to make sure I look
presentable I doubt her he walks in and
I go dude that that's twice you've shown
up with a white shirt he goes I just got
out of shower said oh and they make
towels I'm wicked passionate you brought
it for this show I feel like the first
bought it today for the show there's
wife give me a lunchbox before you clear
your lines plain okay now be sure to
make new friends
my wife legit does that house you sure
you have a good shirt today yeah yeah
cuz like I'm the I'm the type of guy
that just be like why do pants matter I
know what I'm talking you and Stephen or
kidney to your after you raper
just joke with his beard no there's
nothing funny about rape ever there's
nothing funny about funny anymore
you know that right Mike though that
he's been put before human rights you're
a legend dude I didn't even know that
was you this morning yeah much love man
oh thanks prime minister hates him you
know you're funny when you're being sued
by a nation like you're awesome man for
another level thanks ed then it'll be
the next guy he'll we don't he'll be
sued by the First Nations no I can't
even have a dry hoodie and you're being
sued by a nation so in other news before
we get to more Kavanagh a naked man in
Florida
tried to start a fight club at a
chick-fil-a tight as well the witness
said a stranger was challenging her
boyfriend to a fight then she said he
took off his clothes and began yelling
about people stare
at his private part so he did he tried
to start a fight club a took first rule
of naked chick-fil-a Fight Club bro is
never show the police your dick that's
the first and then also second rule of
naked chick-fil-a Fight Club is never
talked about showing people your that's
kind of the first rule it's kind of
reiterating the headline says Fight Club
there but in Florida he actually named
it CrossFit for gays on meth yeah as
it's known in the Central Florida so
brutal CrossFit that's good that's good
branding it is good branding yeah
everything just yeah just be every time
you have any story let says Florida it
could just be replace with me and does
meth like the byline is do we need to
write the rest of the story no it's not
even necessary at that point yeah
they're trying to fluff up the obvious
meth behavior yes you know I think this
also could have just been like a dude
tries to go gay with a guy that wasn't
into it maybe and then covers by
starting fires that gay no no it was a
Fight Club with my mouth I was choking
it with my mouth that was his weakest
point rape decoder ring yeah look I
think this is like if you want us to
fight clubs cool right if you want to
start Fight Club naked fight clubs
probably not like the Greeks you know
it's not gonna work again that's it's
like the Bronze Age is it cool to fight
nude yeah I don't want another man's
Donecker let's cut this is all do you
know why because we have a man whose
name has been absolutely run through the
mud here's some that's really important
I think and I want to get everyone's
opinion here and I want to hear your
opinions on the hearings if you watch
them what's there two things that
occurred one there was there's no new
evidence now by the way keep in mind
here is 0 new evidence there is ZERO
proof that this event occurred okay
nothing today changes that but all of
the news coverage is I was watching ABC
and CNN it's all about the optics yeah
well when this when this old white lady
was when this old why
man when Lindsey Graham made his
comments it's not going to pay the
American public won't look upon it
favorite but who cares
are we really doing I did we're playing
identity politics when we are ruining a
man's like them no you're saying rape
ruins a life too absolutely right it's
just crazy I believe survivors quick
question for you how do you know they're
survivors shouldn't you figure that out
first
should that be the first thing we figure
out elaborate what would the other guy
say is the door to freedom it's easy if
one of them always lies not saying this
woman is necessarily lying but am saying
that the media almost invariably
and verbally lies as it relates to
Republicans any other comments where we
get to the timeline cuz I've got I've
got some time lines and some clips for
you that you probably won't see all
right so just just to lead off real
quick I think we built this up too much
I think we built up the fact that she
wasn't testifying and now that she's
testifying all they're saying like you
said is the optics game they're just so
now that she's testifying you have to
believe her she sounded a little choked
up you've got to believe or she's
telling the truth that's it that's one
of the biggest problems is they're going
off emotion they're saying well she was
crying therefore she's right and as
someone and this is no knocking
ex-girlfriend or someone who used to
live with Golden Globe nominee christine
ricci women can lie on cue women can cry
whenever they want the girls I think it
softens it by me Lister accolade women
are unbelievably good at crying when
like if you get pulled over by a cop
like I've tried to cry to get out of a
ticket and then the cops like bro you're
not even crying convincingly you're
shopping it's like seriously like
multiple time Oscar nominee Roman
Polanski so let's go through force or if
there was Ford in the know and there was
Kavanagh let's go through the Ford
timeline a couple of things were pretty
important first off she can't member who
pushed her into the bedroom either
Kavanaugh or judge or just Kavanagh
but then she tells Diane fine C with Vic
with a very scientific explanation it's
impossible for this to be a case of
mistaken identity
which she uses to establish her
credibility as a psychologist here's the
thing Kavanaugh hasn't even said that
she wasn't sexually assaulted that's not
even
he's actually more gracious than I would
be at the gentleman but maybe there's
mistaken identity maybe she thinks she's
telling the truth
and maybe he thinks he's telling who
knows but the point is there is zero
evidence of the rape occurring let's
continue through the timeline here
she took a polygraph in her hotel room
because she was on her way to a flight
keep in mind these hearings were delayed
because she was afraid of flying no idea
you know that no that's their delayed no
that doesn't make her wrong now keep in
mind it is not our job it is not our job
to either to to vindicate her
accusations to vindicate her credibility
or to condemn it it's to get to the
truth yes yeah the whole purpose for all
of this shouldn't be hurt for the circus
for this reason it should be to get to
the truth now the truth is before this
hearing we had no evidence no witnesses
no hard evidence we didn't know a place
or a date or a time or who we still
don't those look important facts by the
way they are kind of important if it's
gonna be some regret yeah a bunch of -
she flies ok so here's something many
many different versions of the story
she's given about how many people were
present of the party the letter says 4
but the testimony today she said there
could be more she can't be sure she
didn't remember if the Washington Post
reporters ever saw the notes or if she
just summarized them verbally she can't
she can't remember anything do you
notice this team she can't remember
anything other than she's sure Brett
Kavanaugh raped her there was the one
point that she was able to say yes 100%
everything else is a blur but that
really yeah some people are trying to
say well hold on it's short like I can't
remember what I had for lunch but I can
reverse things that happened in grade
school
absolutely but this is not a question of
short-term memory wishes long-term
memory there are a lot of incidents
traumatic incidents she hasn't she can't
remember at all the only thing she
remembers not only does she remember
very clearly that he raped her she
remembers how and the manner doesn't
exactly member who opened the door it
was who was the one person who talked
about she talked about the laughing yeah
just like I remember I remember they're
laughing laughing maniacally like
literally just I'm raping so you can
remember that in graphic detail
if your friends are raped if your friend
is raping someone you're not gonna laugh
no even if you are in on it you're gonna
be like what the hell
wrong you're gonna be punching and
kicking said man yeah if you're the
friend who rapes but if you walk in and
a friend who rapes you're gonna punch
and kick said man yeah you're not you're
a rapist like I don't think the natural
response of a rapist is laughter the
only person that laugh is like Borat
with the naughty naughty but like a
normal human being this is a caricature
okay way to put it it's a character it's
almost like someone wrote down what they
would picture right right this is the
most impactful thing you can say it was
there laughter yeah it doesn't mean it's
untrue but I'm saying I can picture find
him like okay now for research before
the hearing sure watch lifetime what's a
lot of lifetime's yeah Michael Bay's
like is this where something wrong in
the movie exact someone gets pushed in a
flight of stairs and then you learn
exactly how rape happens it doesn't
matter what house the party was in
here's this is something I want to show
this this clip here because I don't
think it was a great a great decision
for the the prosecuting a sexual assault
attorney and I do see obviously that
that Deford could be seen as a
sympathetic character I thought more so
before I washed forward I thought okay
the optics actually aren't good for
Republicans here because of the way
they've gone about this but something
that was really important this was a
pivotal turning moment I think we have
the clip of the I guess sort of the
cross acute attorney this isn't a trial
this is the whole point a trial is to
determine whether someone is guilty or
not guilty the trials already occurred
Ford's life is ruined the whole purpose
of this was to destroy it that's already
done now get that thing I can't see what
do we say cross-exam at this point I
don't know this was really really
pivotal if the goal was to get to the
truth let's watch this clip don't have a
follow up clip have you also educated
yourself on the best way to get to
memory and truths in terms of
interviewing victims of trauma for me
interviewing victims of trying out the
best way to do it the the best practices
for interviewing victims of trauma know
okay she's a doctor let me let me just
stop you one second I disagree with you
I think this was a great
for her to do that imagine a white 55
year old male asking that question yeah
the optics on that are insanely bad Joe
they're having a woman prosecutor just
saying it kind of prefer the woman who I
do librarian I know I never made a noise
so I didn't really hear Anthony Hopkins
yes I would believe Anthony I mean he's
very believable right here's why that's
so important because the this this I
guess you would say prosecutor yeah she
was saying okay there is a way and there
there are criminal studies conducted
where we know the best way to actually
get to the bottom of a sexual assault
it's a forensic interview right he says
there it's typically one-on-one you just
speak they listen and then somebody else
fills in the gaps that's important to
know because if your goal is to get to
the truth if you're coming forward with
and this is where I think everything
changed if you're talking about the
truth this is the moment of clarity for
truth here's why here's the follow-up
did anybody ever advise you from senator
Feinstein's office or from
Representative issues office to go get a
forensic interview no instead you were
advised to get an attorney and take a
polygraph
so right many people advised me to get
an attorney once I had an attorney my
attorney and I discussed about using the
polygraph no one started questioning
your friends in representation if the
goal was to actually guilt go and make
sure that justice was served yeah none
of your representatives told you by the
way you're a doctor you couldn't
research the best way to actually come
forward allegations of sexual assault or
even the most basic protocol it's unreal
to me well she had that she didn't have
a very strong case I mean you have no
evidence that if you went to the police
with this today you would be laughed at
well no the point is her representation
advised her against what one is advised
to do that when making
incredible allegation of assault that's
the point here yeah does everyone around
her said no no what you're supposed to
do if you want to actually get a guy
convicted do the opposite of that right
that's my point they were telling her do
something to me well someone who's
someone very close to me was actually
gang-raped it's like the convictions are
so hard and people like this make those
cases so much more bogged down yeah yeah
you know she went to the hospital
covered in bruises and cuts and all
kinds of things and and nothing eight
months later nothing happened yeah and
it's like that that's why making a
mockery of rape accusations is so deeply
disturbing to me what it really does
shortchange women who have actually been
raped oh yeah of course it hurts
everybody hurts everybody because simply
lying is accepted as believing survivors
now I'm not saying that every woman who
comes forward is lying of course not
that's not what anyone is saying here I
do think I do think she's probably if I
had to BET right now and we'll get to 40
Ernest at 40 look at the cabin all here
in a second I bet he didn't do any of it
yeah none I wouldn't do any of it
I really don't sorry that's opinion
speculation but that's what we got I
think the issue is does she believe it
or not cuz I don't I think the odds are
0% that it happened the way she
described right but I want to know is it
like a collective bunch of just nonsense
in her brain with circus music or like
that she believes or is it just
completely fabricated by the DNC well
the point is it doesn't matter this
exactly
of course yanking place on a national
stage marriage his daughters he has two
daughters they're gonna be mocked for
this this is insane we're watching the
rape and it's not Gavin ah as though as
though this only that's a great point
those only affects men he has two
daughters but any one out there listen
people are coming because you know we're
gonna address the young turks in a
second so people are coming in from that
video The Young Turks let me ask you
this to the feminists it to the female
feminists I should say not the male
feminists the the female feminists it
sounds redundant but now there are male
feminists and they delineate the LGBTQA
I feel I can't keep track of anymore the
point is do you do you not have any sons
or brothers or fathers what if someone
came out and completely falsely smeared
them with the worst possible crime one
can commit arguably short of murder and
there was no evidence whatsoever and he
lost his job and he lost his reputation
oh is it that we talk about putting
yourself in someone else's shoes is it
that hard to do and this is why I said I
do think Ford was a sympathetic person I
think she performed and I don't mean
performance I mean I think she did
pretty well
in answering questions until Ford took
the stand do we have the until cabin I
took the stand we have a clip of that
and this is something that I think is a
we were all talking about you're pretty
tough to fake yeah the night Ashley and
my daughter Liza said their prayers and
little Liza all 10 years old yeah sorry
to watch through them Ashley we should
pray for the woman it's a lot of wisdom
from a ten-year-old we mean we mean no
ill will and here's a couple of things
here um first up that's his pray for
them pray for them that's a stark
conscious from Democratic officials who
called him evil right uh second we were
talking about this because obviously
Ford cried somewhat as well right you
were talking about actors as someone who
can cry for see who's had to do it I
think even on yeah this program we've
done it with parodies sometimes that's
not what that this is entirely
conjecture that's not what that looks
like that was a guy if you watch it was
cut was on the verge and pulled it back
would drink water that's a guy who
wanted to avoid crime was fighting it
why did you try yeah where is it where
as you can tell someone's full of BS
when they're embracing the cry and got
like Jimmy Kimmel when when a lion gets
shot it's like that that that was real
that that was it like when I saw that
earlier today I almost started trying it
was so like tragic I think about my sons
and it's such a good point you made it's
like do women not love their fathers or
brothers or sons or like you're putting
this out to let them just get eaten by
wolves with power
everybody yeah hehe and I think one of
the things that's so heartbreaking is he
shouldn't be in this position right
right I think in the position isn't just
being accused and having your name run
through the mud and have being stained
with this for the rest of your life
the position is now I have to I have to
beat her now like I have to I have to
win this and I shouldn't have to like he
doesn't wish you need a will on her his
family doesn't now but I'm in a position
where I have to fight for my life wicked
it's gonna be John wick now yeah he's in
wicked we run wicked yeah you kill
everybody cuz someone killed your dog
wicked you're getting the pirated
version I was like my parents we had a
favorite Batman film because they didn't
want us to watch the real one and I was
talking with my friends at school yeah
it was well because I was I was like six
so I was talking about action that
wasn't a big one was the old Batman yeah
yeah don't you so uh time went on
Cavanaugh he said I we wanted to see
this is all again I really highly
recommend you go watch this I know it's
long go watch it watch it on two times
or treat if you have to he said he
wanted to hearing as soon as possible
clear his name to manatee hearing the
next day it took ten days and as he
predicted his family and his name have
been permanently destroyed which is
again he talked about his dog
ten-year-old daughter talking about
praying for the woman so it doesn't seem
like a just seemed like a wise girl he
runs through something I think a lot of
people miss here and he pointed out and
if you watch it I think you might have
your aha moment he run through I have
this that are at around timelines here
but it might not make sense for you
because they'll reapplied it from c-span
so I'm just gonna ignore the time codes
but he run through how often he's been
vetted by the FBI and the confirmation
hearings after he was appointed to the
federal bench by Bush do you have any
idea the kind of vetting that goes into
this insane I think a lot of people
don't realize this isn't this is really
really as hard as it gets they're
vetting here and that's why President
Trump is so confident yeah that's why
everyone in the administration is so
confident the media goes well I wouldn't
be so confident I were them and they're
like yeah we're pretty confident yeah
well and she had her chance at every
single one of those other confirmation
hearings
yeah but he had to go through every one
of those positions that right wanted to
if he's really that evil of a person why
was at the supreme court he can do a lot
of stuff at a federal court right in
another position that he without a
spotlight I mean if a guy raped me at a
house party and I found out that he was
going to manage the Kroger down the
street
rape so many people exactly right let me
stop him before Eve before he makes it
to shift manager that's all I would talk
about forever yes I'd be like Bernie
Sanders raped me yes and he did he did
rape me I don't know where or when prove
it can't prove it and can't prove a
negative I'm really upset by how this
show is going it's mirroring he says he
says that he started keeping out I
thought this was really important
because even if this were trial it could
be proven but nobody cares because I
move on to the next thing he said that
he started keeping calendars and Diaries
in 1980 since his dad made a practice of
it and he points to his calendars that
he wasn't at the supposed party in the
summer of 1982 now in a court of law
they would say hold on a second does
this hold up they would be able to look
they would be able to cross-reference
and see if he did have a track record of
writing Diaries and journals and if they
added up that's kind of how they figured
out the Bible and I said hold on a
second was it written when they claimed
that it was written particularly the New
Testament it was there it you know the
standard of a possibility there's a
process for this and this does happen in
a court of law
Diaries and journals if proven to be
valid can be brought in as evidence yes
but guess what here it can't but that's
a that's the most valid piece of
evidence that was brought up all day
that's the only piece of evidence of
whatever we talked about help me talk
about did you see when her lip one like
this his lip is channel one like this
all right I thought was really funny was
a fine see that's why he didn't want the
FBI to investigate and he immediately
said that he did did you watch that rage
rage no because I was thinking about the
fact that should keep a journal every
single guy should keep a journal on
every single thing that he does and the
people that are around him because of
crap like this this is not a witch I
don't like rape as you do against rates
still don't like rape that's the next
episode of Doug did it did it did it
dear journal I don't like raping people
Patti mayonnaise is safe to say there oh
and I'm just looking through my no-good
Patrice O'Neal used to have a joke about
how he would buy something every 20
minutes in case someone accused him of
rape yeah yeah like I was buying gum
yeah
or my head everyone's normal again but
was he also b.i.g related once I'm
already been the same guy alright I
think we're good by the way it's still
the same thing
Cavanaugh says he wasn't there at all
yeah really denies nothing in the
storage the only evidence would be I
would love to see that diary or that
journal okay
here's something else as I do a couple
of points that I think are important as
we move on here because I had actually
written out some of this yesterday
before these hearings took place and we
just said let's just make this a long
first segment because a lot of people
are going to want to know what's going
on and they're not going to want to
watch three hours of c-span but it's so
funny to me that the left demonize you
know Christianity and this idea of this
antiquated morality but they've become
the new Puritans they become the pearl
clutching perpetually offended they're
the church lady
yep it could it could be R drinking
could it be rapists that's what's
happening now so this is it really is
out just quick let's look at some of the
book of men that I'm talking about
sparking the outrage and they've had to
use these plays now right with Kavanagh
yeah so let's hold him to it boogeyman
number one drinking of the alcoholic
beverages so you know Cavanaugh said
that he didn't drink in high school and
not to excess in college so leftists are
clamoring for an investigation into his
drinking habits in high school and
college with a cliff don't leave from
the news this is an actual and by the
way this is something that I had this
morning right I had this in the show map
this morning and then just as I was just
as I was getting ready to walk in
there's continued commentary I heard
someone on CNN say constant [ __ ] theme
seems to read a Cavanaugh likes his beer
what they're using the PlayBook that we
wrote about as their PlayBook in the
morning at night I drank but basically
as a senior he said because the legal
drinking age was 18 18 may have had a
few too many but never forgot anything
never drank to excess so that I blacked
out never did anything like what anyone
is saying Chris I just think it's
absolutely unbelievable and I think the
American people are smarter than this
you cannot reconcile the individual in
the Fox News interview with the
individual who wrote what he wrote in
his yearbook you don't have Chris Cuomo
in Canada do you Mike no you're lucky no
yeah Jennifer
Reuben I think we have one of our tweets
here and then slate said that
Cavanaugh's drinking should be
investigated really that's not new by
the way I think it was what Martin
Bashir asked Andrew Breitbart when
Andrew Breitbart was just absolutely
figuratively raping him
not literally what's what's your
relationship like with alcohol and I
remember Andrew Breitbart stop there he
goes well why are you asking me this I
thought it's a question are there
studies that the alcohol leads to rape
that's a dumbest thing I've ever heard
no leads to high fiving exactly like
wine sales for me so in my mind rapists
are aggressive whenever I drink I'm
happy and I'm mellow yeah unlike name
exactly I think it's probably more so
the CrossFitters on meth who are doing
the radio yeah I'm sure I'm sure bad
sexual decision but they've also of
course they've also tried to define
drunken sex is rape you know but yeah
yeah cannot consent if she's drunk if
that's the case I've been raped by my
wife yeah tons of time I mean probably
been raped at some point myself before
everything is rape sometimes it has to
be raped it's because I feel bad I don't
think people understand how hard it is
to rate comedy right now like that was a
joke this morning like sad tired the
reality is six hours now we know what he
said she runs about where he said she
said not about not even about we're not
even about the regnum about beer in his
national news even if you think he's
lying Arif seriously asking the FBI to
act as the Oppo research arm of the DNC
and investigate people who maybe drank a
beer in college and anything till I know
people say well Steve Hall you talked
about how you know it's true I don't
drink to excess I don't go to I never
went to parties in high school and I
typically don't like to get drunk or
drink too much around strangers and put
myself in a situation that could be
compromising that's absolutely true but
you couldn't bet your ass and as soon as
we're done taping this show oh one
Gerald Mike and I are gonna title might
have a party oh yeah baby yeah make its
ear might be a little rain some gay rape
also known as great group hold on oh
that's a terrorist that was a fun fun
how did you do it my great nuts how its
first rule we go rape you never talk
about never talk about
and don't try to start a fight club with
it look they're trying to paint a
picture that this is animal house and
he's running around yellow toga toga and
drinking beers until he's like blackout
drunk all the time just you're grasping
at straws it is so obvious that your
grasp let's talk about puritanical
outrage yeah that's unreal over that's
teenagers remember this teenagers rory's
me yeah Ralph gets blues and no effects
and Green Day and now you got I don't
know every single celebrity lining up
they had times most 100 100 most
influential people yet meaner to a
ministry I think something like 70 of
them took jet went out of the way to
make jabs at Donald Trump and they
toggle yeah Rage Against the Machine two
left the DNC the party of Bernie Sanders
and and weary Annina Pinta Cortez they
want to disqualify you for a job in
government if you ever had a beer in
college and Obama's like yep I had some
blue yeah wheat is now a domestic terror
I with the good news is I think it's
gonna wake up young males to live a life
more like you're I'm gonna have my kids
live a better life because honestly
because now you can't take the risk it's
like be with one woman don't drink to
excess like don't put yourself in
compromising positions it's oddly having
a very conservative backlash in a good
way like that's the the silver lining it
is true do you try here's the thing
though it doesn't matter you don't put
yourself in compromising situations if
they just make up right they just make
stuff up I've told people I'm like you
can read things that are offensive you
can see thing from pitch means that are
probably far too racist or homophobic
far too transphobic far too vulgar for
the show that never make air and I'm
sure there's some dick pic floating
around probably see this article and you
said it's your friend shirt so listen
yeah there you go that's the dirt on me
go go run wild with it
I did but you know all of a sudden the
left cares about virginity
have you noticed this yeah like he
wasn't there claiming that he wasn't
really a virgin because one of
Cavanaugh's friends came forward
claiming that he had a conversation in
their freshman year of college for guys
saying a freshman year of college we had
a conversation where a here's a clip to
what you're saying that all through all
these years that are
January virgin that's correct never had
sexual intercourse with anyone in high
school correct through what years in
college since we're probing into your
person yes many years after I'll leave
it at then this guy man life comes at
you fast a week ago this guy was
cruising to a lifetime on the Supreme
Court and now he's on TV like I was a
virgin well into adulthood okay is that
what you want to hear have I embarrassed
myself enough for you what's funny is he
actually in that one clip weaponized
virginity and then subsequently admitted
to weaponizing virginity like lifted the
curtain back right away don't you see
how they're good just kidding it's me
I'm a dick right away I know and these
are the same people doing
oscar-nominated movies about sodomy with
a minor I know I know I know
by the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed on YouTube because you
may not actually get anything in your
subscriptions and join my club if you're
watching this on the youtube $99 six
nine annually for veteran students
active military because youtube might
shut us down for this who knows they
might say that like rape joke but the
pedophile channels are still you can
also subscribe in iTunes let's assume
again that Cavanaugh is lying yeah does
his virgin status and college eyes does
that somehow disqualify him from being
in the Supreme Court if he lied about
his sexual conquests or if you lied
about being a virgin I mean if these are
the rules and no one who ever told the
tall tale to impress a buddy could be
able get a job it'd be over you'd be
done by the way this is something again
this is some of the conservatives have
long advocated for so now it's funny to
me that the left again they're the
puritanical purl justice I was I wrote
about not having sex until I guess what
it was the left who locked me birth at
all of us mercilessly Schumer here's a
clip look back when she was thin you
know 23 know you're gonna be sexually
yet you know you slipped by the the
dirty comedian thing but honestly you
call yourself a comedian but you don't
do it that much like I go fishing a
couple times a year but I don't
introduce myself on TV as a fisherman
wow this is really personal for a
comment about absence
what's funny is but it's not funny but
man it's kind of she's pining for the
days back when she had like amanda Bynes
slightly more [ __ ] cousin that was
like that for her was to step up she's
like I wish I could get
back to that dude you look younger she
looks like an orca like literally the
difference in that clip is you look you
have a different haircut he's gained a
hundred and fifty pounds I know I know
and she's miserable too Oh
mr. Udo everyone just in Ellis and
rightfully so some people really didn't
like my opinion but it changed we're
like oh wow she really did prove to be
exactly what he was kind of discussing
the article was the idea that the last
taboo was some sort of idea of moral but
non moral ambiguity what's the word I'm
looking for for non ambiguity moral
moral clarity fortitude
I have right now clarity I do not have I
did not have clarity right yeah I
remember when you did that you actually
wrote an article to that got a lot of
buzz me over the coals for the article
she was like my I just think that was
really judgmental really do tell um I
can guess why you think it was
judgmental Fred probably because they're
trying to see mirrors cut something for
it it's just crazy to me there's no
equivalent even if you lie about it okay
finally number three because this brings
us to the lovely I had their book
boogeyman number three jokes jokes gone
are the days of liberals like Lenny
Bruce because we all know that the left
wants comedy to die slow and painful
death whether by putting you in front of
Human Rights Tribunal and finding you it
was in fifty thousand dollars forty to
forty yeah that's what we thought you
know that's that's that's throwing a
hard right but the jab is just you
shouldn't say that yeah and that's what
we get here in the nature and the jab is
probably worse yeah uh I don't know man
forty two grand yeah I'm not gonna pay
it though yeah I hope you I hope you
look good in stripes yeah we are okay
this is a Young Turks they decided to
finally sack up and attack the orderly
and
in response oh okay why not here you go
this is how they think about comedy okay
so we called her a lying [ __ ] and he
also accused her of calling someone a
rapist with no evidence she did not call
anyone a rapist she accused attempted
rape those were her allegations but more
importantly there was evidence there
were notes where she had spoken to her
therapist on two different occasions in
2012 regarding these allegations there's
that there's also the fact that she took
a lie-detector test that is considered
evidence but nonetheless steven crowder
I mean this is what you can expect from
trash has a name what Oh
trash you envy because you're better
than me I get it okay am I the only one
that saw that Ford sound like a valley
girl too is that bad no I talk about me
time I fourth I did refer to Ford as a
lying [ __ ] in a callback joke from
Wednesday that I made and I subsequently
used the job to explain the call at the
context of accusations and how they can
hurt people and I make no apologies the
context was you know I said listen if
you're just gonna say rapist or
attempted rapist lying [ __ ] yeah look
we can both play that game I met no
apologies I walk it back zero do I think
she's a [ __ ] I have no evidence of that
if I had to make a guess I don't know
fifty-fifty the point is lying [ __ ] is
a pet name compared to rapist that's the
point we're just bring out baseless
accusations fine by the way that should
be the default if you're just going to
yell out rape with no evidence you
pretty good she continues to proceed
with evidence that is not evidence
what's so funny - is the evidence
evidence in quotations of C tensions it
actually served as the setup for
everything she just mentioned was the
setup to the joke that I delivered on
Wednesday see for yourself this is
Wednesday's joke that the attorneys
story conflicts with for yeah if I'm not
mistaken very true and an attorney
originally said that Ford would like to
testify an attorney Ford put on retainer
in August at which point she took a
lie-detector test for an accusation she
claims she was never going to make
publicly at all in investigators by the
way should say that it should be noted
there is still the possibility of Ford
being allegedly a dirty lying [ __ ] it's
almost like she didn't watch the
original joke at all she just makes a
claim she's doing exactly what this
person Ford is doing okay well next
women next no it's a signal to his
misogynistic viewers never respect a
woman Madison I think is in the studio
with two cute Maddy with with overlays
can't get her in the show she
understands just yell it out you
understand that when I say lying [ __ ]
that it's just specifically about the
lying [ __ ] in question and not all
women correct okay never got paid I
think it was all pro bono it's terrible
oh my god all my massages I want you to
do me a favor okay first you have to go
Wednesday shows behind the pit of mud
club so join me I can go watch the
original Wednesday Joker was--let oh
wise the last week's show on Thursday
then I want you to compare last week's
show on YouTube the closing segments
about my wife and finding a good woman
and what women need to look for in a
good man and how men should treat
women's compare that with shanks own
notorious quotes about [ __ ] and
training which by the way was not even a
joke I think we have here from
Huffington Post in case you forgot about
that [ __ ] in training I think is the
turn correct yeah funny thing is
actually a shank says that this program
a comedy show is he goes on to say that
we're like we're averse to factual and
from
but look you got your audience who
doesn't believe in facts oh okay
probably willing to believe anything you
say
I might have to Don the fat suit again
on Joey more but listen you come on the
show for debate I know it's kind of
punching down at this point yeah right
what 20 million from Al Jazeera but you
can have them on the show but there's
audio to hates facts second I would you
want to make sure because we asked you
to call us on our sources information
which we provide you does he mean that's
like this most allegations in that field
are overwhelmingly true meaning that the
great majority of the allegations when
you go to court prove to be true so if
there are there are stats on it and and
so the we didn't pull them out the cases
that are true greatly outweigh the ones
that are false so if you're gonna say
anything at all you would say a turtle
without shame you know what it doesn't
mean that every accusation is true some
or not but the overwhelming majority are
right that would be factual but instead
he turns it around I'm not saying
everyone who says rapist walls but come
on right oh is that what you mean by
fact Young Turks could mean the people
who carry out the Armenian Genocide I
think which I know you deny because
that's a fact or it could mean I think
like short of it also was used as a
colloquialism for young
anti-authoritarian Oh rebelled young
rebels because nothing's more rebellious
than Bernie Sanders Young Turks just
this entire program is run on the budget
of just I think their on-air salary and
you can't do one over later source and
by the way I didn't say any of those
things it's fact that Stevenson not
everyone so they hate facts and what I
mean by facts is stealing I never said
that everyone who comes for an
allegation of rape is lying
but really it's a fact right that he
meant it dummy did it's it's like this
guy it's like oh yeah Stevens this
authoritarian it's like this show is
funded by people getting mugs by foreign
caliphates
it's really tough to make that argument
and I'm gonna corroborate something I
just went on tour and the whole thing
sold out and ton of fans are your family
and some of them are like most of them
are literally the nicest people a lot of
married couples whatever oh yeah a lot
of women a lot of men a lot of people
that are just good-hearted so if you
were an actual misogynist I think
there's a lot of people that don't quite
they didn't get the dog yeah oh no it's
a dog was oh it doesn't work it's like
it would be like a rape whistle that
only calls more rapists defective it
does exactly what it's intended to just
give it some time it says look I think
this is a bad move on their part we were
just beginning to let them go away yeah
but I mean it's just it's so desperate
to like pick on the most fact-based show
out there
we're going along today because this was
such a big event and we're gonna have a
shorter interview with Nicole Arbour
after this and a short wrap-up but I
don't want to get the whole young turks
he-said she-said here because there's no
need to get personal
Steve Crowder is a gross person I hear
high-pitched voices are really funny so
congrats on that steven crowder I mean
this is what you can expect from trash
like him
it's a signal to his misogynistic
viewers no one cries more than a
conservative will crap joke based on
hearsay it's okay when the Young Turks
go low will go high the Young Turks and
unfortunately Samantha bee of their
self-professed comedians they want to
watch comedy die a slow painful death
they want this is this is the party of
people who want to destroy anyone who
has a beer in car college anyone who
loses their virginity later in life or
who doesn't lose their virginity later
in life but maybe lies about it or just
all around whenever you lose your
virginity you're a bad person they clean
up the gang rape and you think if you're
in a fraternity you should be shamed or
that telling a joke is the equivalent to
rape this these are the new Pearl
clutching church lady Puritans that's
what the left is there's been a complete
flip in the culture I miss the old days
back when I left at least used to be fun
you know prinos job I think it's like a
sundial
I don't know that's gonna end this so
well now he looks angry no I don't want
him to squander his yeah all right look
I'm Nicole Arbour after this to talk
about all this and then after that we'll
wrap this up thank you so much huge
Guinness common now like any commercial
break this announcement is for the fans
of the lotto with crowded program the
viewers listeners and downloaders joined
altogether under the umbrella of comedy
and I hope a lot of you guys and gals
were listening out there because I have
something I want you to do for me
October 25th at 7 p.m. at the University
of Michigan's power center in Ann Arbor
lada with Crowder will be broadcasting
live now I know I know it's murder
asking you to leave your computers and
smart devices for a live show in 2018
and certainly performance this
high-energy is no cakewalk although it
shouldn't be too tough for those in the
Michigan area to attend but remember
this all the leftist social justice
warriors and professional protesters in
Michigan are trying to stop this show
from happening they tried to run us out
in a rail last time at SMU and now we're
offering you a chance to rub it right in
their face and fill up this whole damn
theater with laughter which is the
nicest gift you'll ever get from the
nicest live show you'll ever see oh and
they won't know what to do with what do
you do with a protester what he won't
stop being a little [ __ ]
it seems this campus really
one two and three and four small
protesters
[Music]
remember then your objective is
University of Michigan seven o'clock
October 25th at the power center doors
open at six synchronize your watches for
operation louder with crowd
[Music]
so actually the reason needs to do this
fighting stance a big reason forward
like this makes doesn't make yeah
Fighting Irish is exaggerated and stupid
those are probably this a big reason for
it was because they had to protect their
body a lot more in bare-knuckle fighting
because they would go to the body more
otherwise it would break their hands
because they didn't have gloves back
then so it was more like this it wasn't
like this you know that this is a broke
yeah that's like kicks my ass territory
yeah yeah okay our next guest really
glad to have her on and I'm sorry that I
by the way weekend to Paul Joseph Watson
to Josh wolf just with the hearings
going on today it's been an absolutely
the same day but our next guest I know
has a lot to say about it
you can follow her on the Twitter at
Nicole Arbour and her new book is how to
lose the excuses and effing went already
because we're FCC compliant Nicole how
are you hey I'm amazing but I'm actually
legitimately so pissed off right now
okay first let me give you the floor as
to why are you so pissed off because
we've been told that there are no women
in your shoes that that everyone agrees
that this woman not that we should
believe survivors slash accusers club
and as you know me I am not on any side
I like the truth and I'm currently
witnessing the character assassination
of someone based on something with no
facts and it's just it's insane and the
voice when I saw her using her voice
like women use this place when we want
two things either we want something or
we're trying to get away with something
highly speculative but I will defer the
expert witness on that one lady here
right now I'm sure she's a doctor you
stop your talk she's a doctor do you
know what she's a doctor of four I think
that's a psychologist right a clinical
psychologist
no I think she is thirty years to get
over some guy maybe touching her boob
and she's a psychologist well the
allegations are a little bit more
serious than that okay but it's
important though that we get to the
truth like we're talking about yes we
just discussed this it's all about
optics if you watch CNN or ABC all the
groans this doesn't you know look at all
of these white guys questioning this not
on a second this isn't a setup these are
elected officials when you're talking
about right this is the it wasn't a
great decision to have a prosecutors at
the prosecutor who they had but I do
think it was very very key when she
asked for me we just talked about this
the key moment I don't know if you've
been following us today
was where she said are you aware that
the best way to basically get to the
bottom of these kinds of allegations is
a forensic interview and she'd find you
or what it was and Ford said that make
sense and she said did any of your
representation advise you to take part
in a forensic interview and she said no
I'm going there you go if you're looking
for the truth
if you're looking to make it stick
that's what you do and she was advised
Aaron not to do it that to me is so
pivotal she's gotten more coaching the
Serena Williams did and she's not in
trouble for it like she can't answer a
question without deferring to the guy
and for me when I have truth to tell and
I think most women because we like to go
on rants it's easy to bring it out it's
easy I feel like she's overthinking and
it is all about optics and as you know
intelligent human beings we should say
we're character assassinating a man for
life we should be able to step back and
ask for facts and asking for facts
doesn't mean we don't believe women
it means we believe women who can prove
it and I think has to be some kind of
proof like where her friends from the
school where wears anything there's
nothing I can't fly I'm scared of flying
you flew for your vacation last week
that's totally different probably not
you're actually in the minority here
because even a lot of conservative women
and myself included I did think that she
came off as a somewhat sympathetic
figure you don't seem to think that at
all
no I think that something happened to
her in her life but it wasn't this so I
like to study people's physicalities I
like to study all of this stuff I like
to study psychology it's actually my
favorite thing to do I'm 10 years into
my studies of it I believe something
happened to her that triggered all of
these emotions I don't believe it was
this and I don't believe it was him I
think that she had some kind of trauma
go on and then you defer the trauma over
to something that kind of gives you the
biggest story because that's where you
got your payout and people can disagree
with me and they will but and that's
fine but I don't think this happened my
gut is telling me that he didn't do this
no and I understand and listen that's
speculation and we'll both have readily
admit that because it's the truth you
know there is no evidence none it's all
speculation at this point people say
believe survivors yes yes they all said
no every single
person that was questioned that she said
is her witnesses have said they don't
have any recollection of that happening
and by the way that's also the least
reliable form of evidence if there were
one witness so at this point if we've
got three people saying no no and one
person comes forward that would not be
enough here's my question here's a
riddle for you believe survivors okay oh
how do we know they're survivors okay so
I'm gonna preface this with I have beans
for sexual assault many a time and I
don't believe that there's a woman out
there usually who hasn't had some form
of that whether it's harassment assaults
worse you don't have to be believed but
you do have to move on and I think that
powerful women which is what the whole
meaty movement is about to me is about
us taking our power back we'll see that
as a moment in time that you need to
move forward from in order to be a
survivor and not a victim forever and I
just really want people to do that and
not sit in that moment of something that
happened well I also think it's
important not to conflate second sexual
assault or even sexual harassment and
rape those are two very different things
especially you're talking about gang
rape people saying he was literally
cocking his head back laughing while
they ran a train on this person oh
that's like this is as sinister as evil
as it is if all I started to share with
this if all of the people who have come
forward and accused Cavanaugh of raping
them are telling the truth and it is
proven life in prison in the worst
prison possible reopen Alcatraz just for
that son of a [ __ ] I just want to make
sure that my points are clear here but
nothing yet let me ask you this you
talked about this and you got some some
blowback for it
you said that there should be I think
the term was purged deadline at some
point for accusations made against a
person yeah I think you know there's me
too there's all believed women and yes
there are so many evils out there that
need to come to justice let's set a
deadline let's say women this is your
time take the floor or men you know
whatever's happened to you you have
until October 30th Devil's nights just
saying I think it's good and anything
after that I don't want to hear it I
don't think there should be drawn out
forever and wait until someone's running
for a high office that these stories
suddenly come out in this mock Court but
interesting timing but also be the way
this guy was a judge it was a
high-ranking judge it's like well I just
didn't want any lie
to be damaged you some sitting it with
the gavel as a powerful judge for
decades and you didn't think maybe then
you should speak up I mean what if
that's the case if this is true how many
women did he rape it is back to his
judge quarters you're gonna be like at
what point is no power enough if I'm at
a party and I think someone's running a
train on a woman gang raping her I'm
gonna do something cuz that's the kind
of woman I am I mean I mean they're
gonna leave and call the police I'm
gonna get a gun or get someone with a
gun I'm not gonna continue to go to
these parties where they're spiking the
punch with drugs and be like whoops it
was my turn like this just these I'm
sorry that I'm good this is how I get
angry and by the way you know what most
men would do something you know why
because rape culture is a myth most men
go oh wait a second someone someone rape
turns but hey I have a sister or I have
a mother or I have a daughter or I have
a wife they say no no I'm not gonna let
people gang rape somebody in the next
room this idea that men have a secret
main one hey listen secretly we all like
rape laughs like Bert and Ernie we don't
we we despise it working on your getting
by the way that came out last week yeah
I know and I'm pretty sure that one of
them is very I'm pretty sure that Ernie
is the one who's actually sorry Bert is
blinking Morse code look I think that
he's being raped continually in that
dungeon I don't think that it is a
frayed culture yes yes I think and are
not bad and I have had bad things happen
to me and I feel like yeah I can't speak
on it because I have all men aren't bad
and I hope that your female viewers know
that just because one guy was a horrible
person doesn't mean all men are and we
shouldn't have that in our mind and
prejudge say a judge on something that
happened to us in the past he is not
that guy and I think that that's what's
happening right now and it's really sad
and I'm excited to you know see how this
all pans out and I hope the right thing
happens but all guys aren't bad rape
culture I don't know the victim
mentality I just don't
well I think that's an important point
of view for Bill to hear and listen
there's there is a victim culture and
there is being a victim and if you are
raped obviously if someone has sex with
you against your will that's what rape
yeah you're a victim you're a victim of
our moment in that moment what we don't
have to continue to be a victim for the
rest of your life you you know there's
these stories of these harrowing women
from say Africa who were mutilate
horrible things happen and then they go
on to have these amazing freaking lives
and helped you know teach other women
they can't - those are heroes coming out
and crying for however many years it's
not a hero take those tears put them
into something I'm not worried about the
casting couch I'm gonna effin buy it so
that guys can't do that to me anymore
yes but you still think they should file
an actual report and do the forensics
interview do all the do all this stuff
and then you as a strong woman have to
move on that's what needs to happen
yeah I had my ass grabbed one time by a
gay a gay makeup artist at a place on
that yeah it was Israeli and he said
ma'am my boyfriend has the cute buttocks
like you except you didn't say buttocks
I'm actually cleaning this up isn't it
it's mirror that I said buttocks it
makes it so much worse than what he
actually said and grabbed it and I mean
like an actual cuppa and pinch and I
went and I moved on with my day
I know it's not exactly the same but the
point is you are a big Crowder
yes I am gave a 32 waist but a 38 ass
this is just I should be I should have
been a catcher in Major League Baseball
oh honey a video I'm riding a motorcycle
backwards we yeah we can figure that out
listen I appreciate I appreciate you
taking the time and I do think it's
important to separate because people
again just like the young turks did with
with my joke about Christine Ford
earlier this week which I apologize for
zero you know I was thinking okay well
go back to that in the closing segment
but I do want to separate between what
was that I said lots of words don't know
what you mean I'll look into it yeah
yeah you'll see the the previous segment
which just when you when when the show
is our couch because we just talked
about it it was a little long thing I
don't wanna go back into it because
sorry but I do want to make sure that
people don't give you [ __ ] you're
differentiating between yes doing the
right thing going through the proper
legal channels of course in a sexual
crime and then also moving on being as
productive as you can with you life both
can be true you can be a victim of rape
do the right things and then also not
allow it to define you I don't want to
say I'm not trying to speak for women
here but I just want to make sure the
people don't give you flak for something
you didn't say because that often
happens on the show because it's the
show yeah and you know I apologize that
I'm not haha comedian Nicole today I'm
very upset about what's going on I'm
very affected because as much as I am
against anything horrible happening to
women all of the time I'm also very
against the witch hunting that I see
happen and I'm always about truth so
ladies if something has happened to you
please report it go through the proper
channels and then let's find an awesome
way to move on together I think listen I
think most people agree with you on all
of the above it's just been we've been
so polarized and we're talking about the
optics so that is at Nicole Arbour the
book is how to lose the excuses and
[Music]
check one check two check one check two
beer is rape beer is gang rape can hear
MIT beer go oh hello
hi I'm Owen Benjamin and you should join
the mud club because this whole show is
funded by you buying this nice mug
unlike the Young Turks it's funded by a
foreign caliphate yeah I don't know if
we can I don't know if what the legality
is there but you know some money from
terrorists for sure ninety nine dollars
for veterans students our active
military you get the show every single
day as well as the entire see our TV
lineup and this wonderful hand etched
mugging listen we will see you October
25th at U of M mug club members bring
your mug and then you'll get access to
the secret after-party MO club a lot of
it's got a calm slush mug but not mug
club.com that's not a thing just you
know what we got to get we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's called the mime I came in late
dance after I recovered from the
drowning but you know what thank you so
much to mike Ward he wanted me to let
you know too that his special is it
infamous mike Ward CA and his podcast is
to drink minimum
hey look I've got papers here so you
know it's official that everything I
said was this is my face that seems like
it might be fun it was kind of a kind of
a device for David Letterman to use
thank you so much to Owen Benjamin next
we can have more epitome I'm Nick
DiPaolo in third chair on Thursday we
also have a rape culture Smith changed
my mind coming up very soon so you know
I've been fitted for a bulletproof vest
and one of those Mission Impossible
masks for acid attacks we did a life
advice segment yesterday so send your
emails to life advice at lateral credit
calm the second was actually tough love
with your guru dr. Trott I can't claim
him a doctor but really I'm a doctor we
did that whole show yesterday for those
who are mug Club members so it's often
I'm inspired with this this last segment
by a particular email but that we went
to what five six seven he went six
there's a lot of fun people seem to
enjoy it and and hopefully you know
helps helps many people out there let me
let me be really clear about this you
know sometimes some of these segments
are a little more flowery sometimes I
get emotional I'm just you know I'm a
little bit emotionally drained it's been
I have just been pissed off all day I'm
not gonna I've been pissed off all day
I've had this hearing on and I of course
had to take notes write down time codes
what's being said I've had to try and
fad this whole time to wasted a ton of
time trying to fact-check evidence that
wasn't really evidence only to realize
that it didn't matter anyway and wasted
a whole lot of my time it was just like
up just up just a pissed-off firehose
just to have any which way but loose
although it was it was loose wasn't it
fire hoses they're loose in that
hardened but the point is I'm pretty
tired that being said this one's easy
this one's is you're watching the
hearings when you're thinking about how
to navigate it there's one thing that
matters and there's only one thing that
matters truth that's it
truth is what matters if you go through
this process if you go through you know
if you go through life seeking truth if
you make that your number one goal and I
know some people right now who you
Christian Egyptian
just let's just drop that let's drop the
the factions for a second okay
we're talking about truth overall there
are people you know there are people I
know it's pretty easy to see if someone
is consistently seeking truth for to
live in truth in their life notice I
didn't say your truth no doesn't say my
truth the truth there is no my truth
there is no your truth there is no fords
truth and Cavanaugh's truth there is the
truth we don't know the truth right now
this is why this is why this met and
this is why it gets so frustrated with
the media coverage we don't know the
truth do you know why because human
nature if left to its own devices is not
truthful that's why we have the justice
system that we do that's why it's
innocent until proven guilty you've
actually thought of that didn't you set
them said hold on a second why is it
innocent until proven guilty because
that wasn't always the case we want to
return to the city do you want to turn
the Salem witch trials and I know it was
a little hard no no listen that wasn't
always the case in every single society
it's not to be good people when people
talk about hold on a second morality is
is is is circumstantial it's it's
societal okay maybe that's true because
some societies didn't value mercy that's
why I think that you get your mouth you
get your values and your any legal
rights by a creator I do believe in God
you don't have to but the truth is not
always have the same values the jury is
not not all religions share the same
values they don't all worship the same
God but have you ever actually thought
about why is it innocent until proven
guilty why did we when setting up a
system on how to judge people on how to
push information did we say all right
we're gonna have to assume someone's
innocence until they're proven guilty
it's because we know that if people can
use lies to further their own personal
position to advance their own personal
game for power that they will we know
that you see it in politics you see it
in the entertainment industry if people
can lie and if they can do so undercover
if they can be protected by lying and do
it for personal gain
that's why someone's innocent until
proven guilty there's a reason for it
it's so that we don't just say believe
all survivors that's exactly why it's
innocent until proven guilty how do you
know what's a survivor
we have a process to find out if it's a
survivor there's a reason for it and
we've gotten so far off of the beam of
seeking truth here's here's another
little throat you the left sit the
progressive left the people I don't mean
ever but people like the Young Turks
people like the Feinstein's they don't
not only do they not care about the
justice system anymore not only do they
not care about rule of law not only do
they not care about truth they're just
gonna do damage anyway even though it's
not true even though it's not proven
true this is the difference now in the
era of social media this is why truth is
more important than ever because now you
don't just lose your job you lose your
whole reputation the way information
spreads it's like being able to kill
somebody without a shot fired you can do
it too telekinesis Kyle if you were able
to do that just an empty gun that's what
yeah I've got an empty gun but I can
kill you anyway so like men who stare at
goats you just I can cause spontaneous
combustion
they don't need Kevin auto because
they're not even pushing for a trial we
can't even compare it to the Salem witch
trials because someone was burned at the
stake at the end of something that they
saw was some sort of justice in this
case these are just people who we don't
know the exact motives but we do know
that they don't care about damaging
someone's reputation and that's the
thing about the untruthful that's why
it's so important to keep bringing
yourself back to the beam for sure is
I've talked about the most toxic lies or
not only lies that you tell other people
did the lies that you tell yourself
because then you get to a point where
you can't even identify the truth if you
don't start if you don't continue and
start every morning coming back to that
that that beam of truth even if it's if
it's a one inch tight rope and you're on
water skis if you don't make an effort
to you get to the point where you don't
not only do you not care about the truth
you don't care that you've created a
nuclear holocaust in someone's life it
doesn't matter to you so long as you get
yours and let me be really clear if
Cavanaugh
raped as many people who've come forward
I think it's up to 219 now it's like the
McDonald's ticker how many billions
served he is the most successful rapist
of all time and I personally on an
emotional level would actually like to
see see someone like that get the death
penalty and I know people disagree I'm
making a point here let's not get lost
in the weeds and a death penalty for
rapists but
maybe as clear as possible if he raped
all the people who accused him of it
throw the book at him but if he didn't I
feel worse for Brett I feel worse for
potential justice Cavanaugh than any man
that I can think of in recent memory
so I'm saying fry him or my god my heart
goes out to him and I just want to give
the guy and his daughter and his family
a hug polar opposites there's only one
difference between the two it's the
truth that's it nothing else
inspirational seek the truth see you
next week
[Music]